I was talking last time about the
concept of election or choice,
God's choice of Israel,
Israel as the chosen one,
which occurs for the first time in the
book of Deuteronomy and I was talking
about the fact that four Deuteronomy,
the election of Israel,
God's election of Israel means or entails
the idea that Israel is a holy people
holy in the sense of separated to God,
right. That root meaning of holiness,
switched means to be separated
from the common or the ordinary.
So that separation entails separation
from alien peoples and practices that are
inconsistent with the worship of God.
So for this reason,
intermarriage with the Canaanites is
prohibited in Deuteronomy and in fact they
are to be utterly destroyed.
All alien practices are to be removed
from the covenant community. Now,
given that there were
probably no Canaanites, uh,
at the time of Deuteronomy is composition.
According to some scholars,
these texts may be understood as a
kind of internal polemic against those
elements of Israelite society whose
practices didn't conform to Deuteronomy.
He's a y'all way only policy
or Yahweh only the ideals.
This is an idea we'll come back to in a
minute. I just want to throw it out here.
Um, separation entails also
separation to God's service.
That means, of course, the observance of
his laws, especially the laws of purity,
the rejection of pagan
practices and so on.
So the privilege of having
been chosen or singled out, uh,
of being a holy people to God entails
obligations and responsibility at the same
time.
It's interesting that Deuteronomy seems
to be aware of some of the dangers in
this idea, the danger
of, um, of a superiority,
sort of a superiority complex, a moral
danger involved in the notion of election.
So Deuteronomy Warren's repeatedly,
it is by no special virtue or merit
that Israel was the one chosen and Moses
admonishes the Israelites not to suppose
that their inheritance of the land of
Canaan is due to their own powers,
are on account of any righteousness
or virtue that they possess. In fact,
he says far from it,
Israel was chosen by Calloway as an act
in an act of spontaneous love does not
imply her perfection and act of
spontaneous love for the Patriarchs.
And the election was entirely God's
initiative and is no cause for Israel to
boast.
So in Deuteronomy chapter seven verses
six to eight read for you are a people
consecrated, made holy to the Lord
your God of all the peoples on Earth,
the Lord your God chose you
to be his treasured people.
It's not because you are the most
numerous of peoples that the Lord set his
heart on you and chose you.
Indeed you are the smallest of peoples,
but it was because the Lord favored
you and kept the oath he made to your
fathers that the Lord freed you with
a mighty hand and rescued you from the
house of bondage from the power
of Pharaoh, King of Egypt.
So don't be tempted Moses later,
Warren's the Israelites.
Don't be tempted to say to yourselves,
this isn't Deuteronomy eight to 17 my
own power and the might of my own hand
have one this wealth me or again to say,
and Deuteronomy nine verse four the
Lord has enabled us to possess this land
because of our virtues.
On the contrary,
he emphasizes it's only because of the
wickedness of the Canaanites is so great
that the Lord has to drive them from his
land. And now he's giving you a chance.
But it's conditional for
you just as it was for them.
Don't fail him or he will drive you out.
Just as he drove out the Canaanites.
That's a theme.
And Deuteronomy we're going to see in a
moment how important that is or in a few
lectures,
how important that idea is for the
Deuteronomistic historian in general.
But we'll get there.
And another theme in the book of
Deuteronomy is the theme of providential
concern.
And that appears in Deuteronomy eight.
God's providential love and care for
Israel is expressed through various
metaphors in the Bible and the Prophet
Hosea who seems to have very strong
connections with the book of Deuteronomy,
the Prophet Hosea will develop further
this image of parent and child. Um,
that occurs in Deuteronomy eight.
So in a way,
the language we were just referring to
was really the language of husband and
wife. You know, someone who
is simply loves someone,
not because they're perfect,
but that's their choice.
They favored them,
they love the person and
they make a bond with them.
It doesn't imply anything
about other people's,
it's simply that's the person who has
been the focus that we have a lot of sort
of love and marriage imagery, husband and
wife, imagery used for God and Israel.
But we also have this parent and child
imagery that appears in Deuteronomy 32
verse 10. The image is that of an eagle
that bears its young on its wings.
He found him in a desert region
in an empty howling waste.
He and girded him watched over him,
guarded him as the pupil of his eye,
like an eagle who rouses is
nestlings gliding down to his young.
So did he spread his wings and take him,
bear him along on his pinions.
The Lord alone did guide him and almost
seems to play on the idea that when, um,
when teaching its young to fly,
the Eagle will push them out of the nest,
swoop under them, bear them
up for a while, over and
over until they get the idea.
So God is repeatedly
testing and correcting the
Israelites until they're ready
for the promised land.
So Deuteronomy is content,
which are these farewell speeches and
the death and the burial of Moses are a
fitting capstone to the pen to Tukul
narrative. But at the same time,
Deuteronomy really doesn't bring closure
to this narrative because at the end of
Deuteronomy,
the promises still are not fulfilled.
The people are still outside the land.
Some have suggested that
this is quite purposeful.
It points to an exact date for
the works final composition.
That is to say when it was
finally a redacted, the,
the redactors were in exile writing
for a people living in exile.
And the deuteronomist wants to make it
clear that it's fidelity to the Torah, uh,
rather than residents in the land. That
is critically important. But in any event,
Deuteronomy is not simply the concluding
book of the Pentateuch or the story
that began in Genesis.
It's also the first part of a
much larger longer literary work.
As I mentioned last time,
a work that runs from Deuteronomy
through to the end of second kings. Um,
and we're going to consider a today the
program and the work of this so called
Deuteronomistic school.
Um, but before we do that,
I wanted to just make a few
concluding remarks about um,
source theory and the pentitude.
We've talked about the documentary
heights thought hypothesis,
we've talked about the different sources
that scholars believe they've been able
to identify as comprising. Um, the,
the five books of the Pentateuch. Um,
and one of the things I mentioned a couple
of times are some of the debates that
occur on the question of dating.
There's a great deal of
ideological baggage that's
involved in the dating of the
sources.
One of the issues that I think is a real
problem is the fact that the priestly
source p is so often
misjudged and maligned.
I hope that the little bit of time that
we spent on the proxy materials gave you
some appreciation of its transformation
of older Israelite rituals and
traditions into symbolic practices that
would communicate basic convictions
about morality, convictions,
about holiness. Um,
I'd hope it gave you a sense
of its communal ethic, um,
as opposed to an individual morality.
The idea that the actions of every
individual have an impact on society as a
whole,
but the anti priest anti cult sentiment
of European Protestantism is apparent in
the history of Biblical scholarship
in the last few centuries.
And it's a apparent in that scholarships
negative assessment of the priestly
source of the Bible. So for
warehousing, the priestly source,
which emphasizes cult and ritual,
logically,
it had to represent a late degenerate
stage in the evolution of Israelite
religion because priestly
ritualistic cultic practices,
these are degenerations,
these are movements away from true,
a spirit filled religion in,
in his view.
So according to that housing,
the early period of ancient Israel
must have been characterized by a free,
more natural form of religion,
intimate relationship with God,
an unencumbered or unsullied
by the legalist stick.
Cultic obsessions of priests and cult.
He argued that in five 86 with
the destruction of Jerusalem and,
and the people were, were taken
into exile in Babylon. Um,
that was when in Babylon the priests
were able to assume control and they were
able to play on the exiles overwhelming
feelings of guilt and failure.
And the priests were able to construct a
new identity and religion that stressed
the sinfulness of the people
and the need for ritual,
purity and ritual observance and
legalism as the road back to God.
And they were able to write themselves
back into the narratives and stories of
Israel's past. And this, according to
val housing, was a degeneration. Well,
this reconstruction of the
evolution of Israelite history, uh,
is Israelite religion,
excuse me,
has really driven more by theological
prejudice than it is by historical
evidence.
And it stems from an obvious projection
of the Protestant Catholic tension onto
Israelite history.
It also is driven very much by a
succession as account of Judaism as being
something that was more abundant at the
time of Jesus. Jesus came and revived.
This was a spirit filled religion,
again when it had decayed and withered
and degenerated like a dead tree as well.
Housing refers to it.
This isn't to say that all scholars
who date p to the post exit period,
um, are motivated by the
same problematic assumptions.
That's certainly not the case.
There are scholars of all stripes and
allegiances who view p as late and there
is some very good objective evidence for
dating parts of p to the postings Zelig
period,
just as there's good objective evidence
for dating parts of d and the other
sources to the post exhilarate period.
So when it comes to dating the sources,
certainly I would say all scholars agree
that the priestly materials reached
their final form in the exile or post
Zelig period. So that's the sixth century,
right? You're going to find
out we're going to return
from exile and the five 30.
So, okay. So when we talk about
the post exhibit a period,
we're talking about the period after
the return. So the period of the exiles,
the sixth century, the bulk of the
middle of the sixth century. So, um,
it certainly reached its
final form in that period,
as did Deuteronomy and the pedagogue
probably generally. Nevertheless,
there are many data that suggest that
the priestly sources retain very early
strata just as d contains preexist or
early material p espouses a communal
ethic,
uh,
and post exhilarate priests are going
to turn increasingly to an individual
ethic. Many sections of p do not
seem to assume as central sanctuary.
You remember that there's the idea of
the central sanctuary really took hold in
six 22 with Josiah and Josiah is reform.
So it becomes a real watershed
for us in dating texts.
Texts that are happy with the existence
of shrines throughout the land of Israel
are probably pre Josiah.
Pre six 22.
Preexist like texts that insist on a
central sanctuary are probably Josiah's
time or later.
Um,
and there are many sections of p that
don't seem to assume essential sanctuary.
There are sections of p that do seem
to assume a central sanctuary more
significantly. I think p contains
no universal ban on intermarriage.
It doesn't employ its purity laws or
language to mark and inseparable boundary
between classes within Israel or
between Israelites and gentile.
Others they use of purity and purity.
Language to inscribe boundaries between
Israel and other nations is very
characteristic of the
post exhilarate period.
We're going to see that when we get there.
So it's very hard to understand
[inaudible] silence in
this regard if it stems
entirely from the post
[inaudible] priestly circles.
So I think that instead of charting an
evolution or a degeneration as I have
over on the side of the board and
evolution or degeneration from Je,
the pure spirit field, religion
to d, the humanitarian,
ethical religion to p cultic
obsessiveness, guilt ridden, uh,
legalism as has done or implied
in some classical source theory,
some not all,
it may be better to see these three as
really representing three distinct and
roughly contemporaneous strands of
ancient Israelite tradition and experience
told from their own perspectives.
These materials were transmitted and
developed by different circles within
Israelite society over centuries and they
crystallized at different times. Jay,
he has fragments that are quite old,
but it probably reached its final
form before the centralization of the
sanctuary. It's still comfortable
with the existence of many, um,
sacred places throughout the land.
So probably before six 22,
Deuteronomy contains northern traditions
from before the fall of Israel,
which was in seven 22 but it was
clearly finalized in the exile.
There are many passages that make it
clear that it's written from an exit
perspective and the priestly
source likewise contains many,
many older traditions,
but reached it's full and final form in
the exilic or post exhilarate period.
So each of these complex, multilayered
sources, each one of them,
you can find different layers.
Each one possesses its own emphases,
its own agenda, it's own perspectives.
Sometimes they compliment one another,
sometimes they challenge
and contradict one another,
but they are not best seen as linear
as telling a neat linear story about
Israelite religion.
Flowering and feeding their diversity
has not been flattened or homogenized by
the final editor of the text.
It's been preserved in a manner that
stimulates reflection and debate.
So with those concluding remarks,
we're going to move on now to the
second major section of the Bible.
We've been discussing the Torah or pen
to Tuk and now we're moving on to the
section of the Bible that's
referred to as the profits.
This section of the Bible is,
is divided into two parts we refer to as
the former profits and then the latter
prophets.
The form of profits will concern us for
the next few lectures and the form of
profits include the books of Joshua
judges first and second Samuel First and
second kings.
They read as a historical narrative.
This material is a theologically oriented
account of Israel's history from the
conquest of Canaan or what's represented
as the conquest of Canaan to the
destruction of the state by the
Babylonians in five 87 five 86 BCE.
This material is therefore crucial
background to reading the latter prophets.
Now the latter profits
is a collection of books.
Each of which bears the name of the
individual who's prophecies it purports to
contain.
These prophecies were,
these profits delivered their oracles at
critical junctures in Israel's history,
in the nation's history.
So their words are only going to make
sense to us if we first understand the
particular historical crises
that they are addressing.
And that the historical narrative that
runs from Joshua through second kings
provides that information.
It tells us of the critical junctures in
the nation's history and that will help
us send slot the different in.
So the former prophets or the historical
books like the books of the Bible that
we've already studied,
um,
contained various older sources that
have been put together by a later hand.
You have an editor or a group of editors
who reworked these older sources.
They were oral traditions.
Some of them were probably records
from royal royal archives and so on.
And they wove them together
into the form that we have now.
And that's a process that's referred to
as redaction or editing the anonymous
person or group or a school that's
responsible for the final composition.
The final redaction of these
books inserted would put
the materials together by
inserting versus and speeches that would
frame the older sources and link them
together, give them some sort
of common uniting thread.
The redactors linking and framing
passages and their revisions of the older
sources exhibit certain common features.
They harp on the same
themes over and over again.
They use some of the same language
over and over again. They have,
they share certain assumptions and those
features and assumptions have a lot in
common with the book of Deuteronomy,
a lot in common with the book of
Deuteronomy and that's what led the German
scholar Martin note
to surmise that Deuteronomy and these
historical books really form a unit so
that Deuteronomy not only looks back
and finishes off the pentacle narrative,
it looks forward as the beginning of of
really the historical account that's to
follow j e and p really
seem to come to an end here.
There's some debate about this,
but because the interpretive history
that runs from Joshua to second kings is
based on ideals that are set
out in the book of Deuteronomy,
we refer to the person or the persons
who redacted this whole unit as the
Deuteronomistic historian or
the Deuteronomistic school.
The whole unit as a whole was
redacted after six 22 that's clear.
It assumes and insist upon the
centralization of the cult.
The last dated event that's
mentioned in second kings is uh,
something that occurred in five 62.
That was when [inaudible] was released
from prison in Babylon in five 62.
So the work was probably
concluded shortly after that date.
So in exile or towards the
end of the exhibit period,
Martin note assumed that
there was one editor.
Other scholars have assumed that
there were two or even more success of
additions of this history because there
are multiple perspectives that seem to
be represented. But the last
seems to be an exit perspective,
the perspective of someone sitting in
exile and will be returning to that in a
future lecture. Some of the books
within this very large unit,
or at least the traditions within this
very large unit are less influenced by
Deuteronomy and its themes and
its concerns. Some are clearly,
um,
some contained clearly pre Deuteronomistic
elements and materials if you will.
But I encourage you to read the
excellent introduction to the profits,
the section of the Bible,
the prophets,
which was written by Mark Breton
there and you're Jewish Study Bible.
I think it's an excellent introduction
to the complexity of this material.
The most salient feature of
the Deuteronomistic school
is the conviction that
Israel's residents in the land is a
function of it's obedience or disobedience
to the covenant with Yahweh Way.
And that conviction is going
to color it's presentation,
it's evaluation and it's interpretation
of Israel's history and her kings. Um,
right from Joshua,
right through to second kings,
it has called Koufman uses
the term historiography,
which I've written up here,
historiography to describe this material
where a historian might simply record
events as if that's such
a simple thing to do.
But let's go with that for a moment. I'm
a historian, might simply record events,
however,
selectively or partially you might
try to indicate cause and effect where
possible. But a historiography is a
more conscious philosophy of history.
It's seeking to ascertain
the meaning of events,
to draw larger philosophical,
ideological conclusions from the events
of history and to point to the larger
purpose or design of history. Not to
just say, not to say just what happened,
but to say why it happened and what it
means for us today that it did happen.
So the Deuteronomistic history is not
simply a history of Israel until the
destruction of Jerusalem.
It's a historiography. It's,
it's making an argument and it's,
um,
attempting to communicate the meaning and
the significance of the events of that
time. And it does. So through
a pattern, a literary pattern,
we will see a reward and punishment.
This is an important point and as
we begin to go through the material,
we'll be coming back to this
will be turned to this idea. Um,
there are certain key
features of Deuteronomistic
thought that are evident from
Joshua through second kings.
One is the belief in the
divine election of Jerusalem.
Jerusalem is the city that is referred
to a Deuteronomy when it says God will
choose a place to cause his name to
dwell in the Deuteronomistic books.
That place is going to be Jerusalem.
There's also a belief in the divine
election of David David as the king of
Israel and his dynasty.
Now it's interesting because the other
four books of the Pentateuch never
mentioned a king and never talk about
genesis through numbers. There's no,
none of the legal materials say,
you know, when you have a king,
this is what he shall do. It's only the
book of Deuteronomy that assumes or, uh,
prepares for a monarchy and contains
legislation for a king and the things that
he should do.
So this again underscores the connection
between Deuteronomy and the following
books.
Deuteronomy assumes a king.
It's being written in redacted at a
time when there is a king in Israel.
There have been kings in Israel and it's
providing laws for the, for the, um,
construction of an ideal monarchy.
So David,
the theme of,
of David as the elected King of God,
David also as the ideal king,
um, is something else that's
a theme of these books.
Um, another theme that we see in
these books or um, feature of the,
the Deuteronomistic school
is the emphasis on, um,
what we call the yard waste
profits. Yeah. Was prophets,
prophets like Elijah and Elisha,
these profits are held up as heroes
and champions of religious purity.
They are completely against any kind
of mixture of Yahweh worship with other
elements, any kind of
syncretism. The other thing,
the other thing we see in
the Deuteronomistic material
is a preference for Judah,
the southern kingdom as compared with
a very negative presentation of the
northern kingdom, Israel,
the northern kingdom.
Israel is going to come in
for very, very bad press, um,
at the hands of the
Deuteronomistic writers,
which shows that they are probably
a favor or come from Judah.
So the northern kings are going
to be uniformly denigrated.
They're going to be denigrated because
they maintain cults that rival the
central sanctuary Jerusalem.
And this is going to be what does them in.
The other theme that we see throughout
the Deuteronomistic material is the
negative presentation of the Canaanites,
but we'll talk more about
who these Canaanites were
and how complicated. In fact,
that presentation is now the books
of Joshua and judges that open the
Deuteronomistic history.
These books recount or relate the story
of the conquest of the land of Canaan by
the Israelite tribes and the
early years of the settlement.
And that's in judges to gain
an understanding of some
of the issues involved and
the emergence of a tribal
structure in the land.
It's helpful to know something
about the geography of Israel,
which is why I've handed out for
you, um, a couple of different maps,
but one that gives you physical
features and that's, that's on the top.
It has often been pointed out
that in the past 4,000 years,
more wars have been fought
for the possession of the
tiny strip of land known as
Canaan or the land of Israel or Palestine.
Then had been fought for almost any other
area in the world and in the ancient
world. The reason for this was
that this very small rectangle,
it's about 150 miles long and 70 miles
wide. It's about the size of Rhode Island.
It's very small.
Rectangle lies on the way to anywhere
worth going in the ancient near east.
You've got Egypt over here,
you've got Asia mine up here,
and you've got Mesopotamia over here.
Not a tremendous amount of inherit
value in this strip of land,
but it's important for where you
could go by traveling through it.
So you have three main trade
routes that cross the country.
And they were used by trading caravans
that would carry gold and green and
spices and textiles and other goods
between Egypt and the rest of the fertile
crescent up into Asia Minor.
So control of these international highways
brought a great deal of wealth to the
area.
But the central location was a double
edged sword because in times of peace it
would bring per stair at prosperity.
But of course, uh, in times of war,
the land was perpetually invaded as
armies would crisscross the land going off
to do battle with the great powers.
Um,
so on their way to conquest in Egypt or
Asia minor or Mesopotamia armies would
tramp through the land and that explains
the succession of rulers that have held
the region, the Egyptians, the
Amorites, the Israelites, the Assyrians,
the Babylonians, the Persians, the Greeks,
the Greek Ptolemies, the solutions,
the Romans.
And the list continues as we go on into
the medieval and the modern periods.
Now, despite the fact that this
is a very small piece of land,
it boasts great geographical diversity.
So there are three main
geographical subdivisions.
You can see them on your map and they
really run in strips from north to south.
If you look at your map, you'll
see first on the, on the west side,
you've got a low coastal plains,
about 20 or 30 miles wide.
It's the coastal plain
and that provides the,
or that is the main highway
out of Egypt or down to Egypt.
That area was controlled by Egypt at
the purported time of the exodus running
north to south.
Next to that coastal plain
is a region of low mountains.
These low mountains are cut by some
valleys that sort of run east west.
You'll see one there. The Valley
of Jezreel in particular, um,
that was a particularly fertile valley.
So the valleys that cut through the
mountains are extremely fertile. Um,
the plaintiff Maketto also joins with
the valley of Jezreel. That's, uh,
the most fertile part of the country,
but it was also the site of many of the
most bloody battles in Israel's history.
Then next to that,
north South Central Hill country,
you've got also running north to south,
what we call the great Jordan Rift Valley
goes the entire length of the country
and the Jordan River
runs through this valley.
It rises in the Sea of Galilee
or the confederate in the north,
and then it flows about 65 miles,
I believe,
down to the Dead Sea at the
northern extreme of this rift,
the Rift Valley is Mount Hermone,
which is the highest point.
It's a snow covered mountain Hermone
and that's the highest point in Israel.
It rises about 10,000
feet above sea level,
the central mountain area,
those are between 4,000 and
10,000 feet above sea level.
As you move from the central
area over to Jerusalem,
Jerusalem is about 2,500
feet above sea level.
But then as you continue moving
east towards the Rift Valley, um,
that area is dramatically lower and you
feel it as you travel the road there
just to how quickly it drops so that by
the time you get to the Sea of Galilee,
you're 700 feet below sea level and the
Dead Sea is nearly 1300 feet below sea
level. That is the lowest point
on the earth's land surface.
So it's dramatic drop and just a very
short geographical area up in the north.
The river surrounded by very
lush vegetation on both sides,
but there's no life 65 miles
south down by the Dead Sea.
And this is because the water
is 25% salts and minerals,
although I hear they found some
sort of bacteria or something there.
So I guess I shouldn't say
any more that there's no life,
but essentially there's no life.
We would care about in the Dead Sea area.
So it's a very desolate area and tradition
identifies this as a site of Sodom
and Gomorrah. The area around
the sea is basically semi-desert.
We call this the Wilderness,
the Wilderness of Judea, um,
between Jerusalem and the Dead Sea,
the Wilderness of Judah, Judea.
So within this relatively tiny area,
there are radically diverse,
uh, regions and this fact held important
implications for Israel's history.
Unity was difficult
being somewhat isolated.
The inhabitants of each region developed
a distinctive economic and cultural
character. Uh, you have the small
settled farmer in the more fertile areas.
You have semi nomadic shepherds,
you have city dwellers,
you have merchants and traders who are
handling the commerce on the trade routes
and enjoying broader cultural context.
So that's the geographical setting for
what we're about to read in the book of
Joshua. The structure of Joshua
is really somewhat simple.
We can really divided
into two major parts.
The first 12 chapters form a unit
that convey the invasion and conquest.
There are certain important
elements. In chapter two, we have,
Josh was sending out spies to scout
out the land. And chapter three,
we have the account of crossing
the Jordan River. In chapter six,
we have the battle of Jericho. Um, the
story of the battle of Jericho is really,
um, a composite of two accounts that
have been a woven together into a single
narrative.
So when one of them,
Josh was warriors seem to March silently
around the city seven times in another,
the priests carry the Ark around
the city 13 times. So the scholar,
since there are two different
accounts here woven together,
chapter eight describes the victory
at a place called [inaudible],
which is near Jericho.
Um,
chapter nine tells the story of the Ghibli
Knights who join the Israelites they
are and a local group
that seemed to join them.
And then 10 and 11 give us to
further military campaigns.
11 towards the end of 11,
we have summary statements in Joshua 10,
verse 40, uh, we read.
So Joshua defeated the whole land,
the hill country and the negative.
That's the desert here to
the south and the low land.
So you have the hill country, the lowland
and the slopes and all their kings.
He left, no one remaining but
utterly destroyed all that breathed.
And chapter 11 goes on distress at Joshua
completed the task that had been begun
by Moses in verse 15 just as the
Lord had commanded his servant Moses.
So Moses had charged Joshua.
And so Joshua did,
he left nothing undone of all that the
Lord had commanded Moses. And again,
in verse 23 the insistence just thus
Joshua conquered the whole country,
just as the Lord had promised,
Moses and Joshua assigned it to Israel
to share according to their tribal
divisions.
And the land had rest from war.
So chapters 13 and 21 go on to describe
the division of the land among the
tribes.
And then we have some sort of tidying up
at the end were the remaining chapters
are, um, upenn disease.
23 is a farewell address and 24 is
a renewal of the covenant at Chapin,
which brings everything
to a nice conclusion.
So the narrative and the
first part of Joshua.
Joshua two to 12 describes the invading
Israelites as an organized Confederation
of 12 tribes whose conquest
is accomplished in a few
decisive battles under the
military leadership of Joshua and the
disunited Canaanites put up little or no
resistance. They're paralyzed
by a fear that's sent by God.
All of those who were conquered
are put to the band or the Harem.
That's the sacred devotion of
objects and persons to God,
which entailed killing them.
So they were utterly destroyed.
So the first half of the book of Joshua
contains a streamlined and idealized
account according which to which the
Israelites managed in relatively short
period to take the central hill country,
confining the Philistines to a little
strip here on the coastal plain will come
to the Philistines in a minute.
The account of the Conquest in Joshua two
through 12 is concerned to express the
basic idea that Israel is victories
would not have been possible without
Galloway, without his wondrous
help. It was your way.
Who divided the Jordan before them?
It was Yahweh who broke down the
walls of Jericho. It was, yeah, way.
Who put fear in the hearts
of the Canaanites. Yeah.
Way was present at every battle.
The Ark was a visible sign of his
presence and at marched before them.
And soon after the conquest
representatives of all of
the tribes of Israel are
going to meet and make a solemn covenant
at Chef [inaudible] to be the people of
y'all way to worship him alone.
And according to the book of Joshua,
Israel's tribal structure assumed
its classical form at this time.
This is a very neat picture of
the rapid conquest of Canaan,
but it's at odds with statements elsewhere
in Joshua and in the book of judges.
For example,
the victories in chapters two through
10 are confined to a very small area.
What would actually be the
tribe of Benjamin basically.
So just one small area.
And Joshua 13 verse one Joshua 13 opens
with the statement that Joshua was old,
advanced in years and there was much
of the land remaining to be possessed.
And Joshua 10 which is in the
first part of Joshua, right?
So Joshua 10 versus 36 to 39 report the
conquest of several cities in the south,
including Hebron and deveer.
But in judges we read that
they hadn't been captured.
They were captured later
after Joshua's death.
Joshua 12 verse 10 reports the defeat
of the king of Jerusalem in judges eight
or judges one verse eight and 21 we
read that the people of Judah did this,
conquered the king of Jerusalem,
and that despite that victory,
they failed to actually drive out the
inhabitants, the Jebusites who live there.
And it's not until King David
200 years later that in fact,
we will read about the
capture of Jerusalem.
Judges one gives a long list of the
places from which the Canaanites were not
expelled.
Also,
archeological evidence contradicts the
picture in Joshua in the ancient near
east destroyed cities tended to be
leveled and then a new city would just be
built on top of the ruins and you would
have these slowly rising mounds and that
each one of those is called a tail,
right? So you may have heard of tell door.
These aren't mounds which represent
the successive layers of destroyed and
rebuilt cities and excavations.
We'll reveal the destruction layers,
um, under the floor of new cities.
So following the biblical account,
we would expect evidence of a 13 century
destruction of Canaanite cities and
archeologists for a long time were
convinced that they would find these
destruction layers. Um,
but they were disappointed.
They have found really no evidence of
extensive conquest and destruction in 13th
and 12th century archeological layers.
Some of the sites that are said to be
destroyed by Joshua and the Israelites
weren't even occupied in, in
this period, the late Bronze Age,
beginning of the Iron Age, right?
The Iron Age begins around 1200.
So excavations at Jericho and I indicate
that both of these towns were laid
waste at least 200 years before
the probable time of Joshua.
So there weren't even any walls in
Jericho at the time of Joshua of 20
identifiable sites that were said to be
conquered or captured by Joshua and the
next generations only to show
destruction layers for this time. Hud,
soar and Bates l.
And yet interestingly enough,
HUD source capture described Joshua
is contradicted elsewhere in the Bible
because in judges four and five,
it's still a Canaanite city.
It said there that it's still a Canaanite
city and Joshua failed to take it.
So the conclusion one can draw from all
of this is that Joshua two through 12 is
a kind of ideological construction.
The significance and the purpose of
which we'll come back to in a moment,
but clearly the formation of a nation
state Israel was much more complicated
than the picture that's
presented in Joshua.
Two through 12 scholars have proposed
three possible models to explain the
formation of Israel.
The first is an immigration model.
This was first posed by a German scholars,
um, since the main Canaanites cities that
existed in the land at that time were
fortified, are walled cities down
on the plains, the Israelites,
it's thought according to this model
would have entered and they would have
occupied the very sparsely
populated central highlands.
They would slowly have
began to take control of the
plane's coming down from the
highlands. While we do know that
at the end of the late Bronze Age,
beginning of the Iron Age around 1200.
This was a time of great upheaval
throughout the Mediterranean world.
You have the collapse of Mycenaean
civilization, you have the Trojan wars,
the Hittites are Asia minor, modern,
modern day Turkey, uh, to the north.
And these upheavals are leading to
mass migrations, migrations of people.
Many are sailing from mainland Greece
and from the Greek islands and they are
flooding this area there, the coasts of
Phoenicia, the coast of Canaan and Egypt.
And these people are,
are spoken about in a lot of our ancient
sources are referred to as peoples of
the sea coming in from the sea, from
islands and coastal areas of the north,
eastern Mediterranean,
one of these peoples of the sea.
One of these groups
inhabited an area here.
One of these groups put
Rasta harassed or per lasta.
This is the word Palestine comes from
this Podesta, pilaster or Philistines.
It's all the same route.
Um,
and so a group of these see peoples
comes in and occupies this area.
They will be the Philistines.
The area that is now the Gaza Strip and
they found the five Philistine cities
that you'll hear about
increasingly in the book of judges,
Gaza Ashkelon got Ashdod and Eq.
Ron,
the idea of the integration model is that
Hebrew settlement would have probably
occurred at about the same time. I'm
in the latter part of the 13th century.
The Hebrews could take advantage of all
of these upheavals and the weakened hold
of Egypt, right? Remember each
of Ted Control of this area,
but their grasp is weakening with the,
with the flood of people
coming in from the,
from the sea and other migrations there
hold is weakening and the Israelites
would have,
or the Hebrews would have been able to
take advantage of that and enter in and
occupied areas in the central highlands.
The problem with the immigration model
again is the archaeological record.
Archeologists have indeed found several
sites in the central hill country.
It's just pretty exciting and they're
clearly newly established in the 13th,
12th,
11th centuries.
So clearly something new was happening in
the central highlands at this time. Um,
it also extends throughout the land
but mostly the central highlands.
And these are thought to be Israelite
especially because they appear in places
that the Bible identifies
as strongholds of Israel.
So you remember also you have their Moneta
a steel of 1204 in which the Egyptian
Pharaoh boasts that he
managed to wipe out Israel.
It's obviously a hyperbolic boat boast,
but the point is it shows that there was
an identifiable entity Israel in Canaan
by 1204.
Um,
these new 13th century settlements,
however,
are in their material culture. That is
to say their, their pots in their jars,
in their houses entirely
Canaanite inhabitants seem
to have been peasant farmers
like other Canaanites.
One interesting difference is
the absence of any pig bones,
which is kind of interesting.
But in any event,
this suggests that these settlements
were established peacefully,
not by a group coming in and,
and conquering.
Maybe they emerged from
within rather than, um,
being established by people's
immigrating from without.
So there are two other models.
Then other model is different from the
immigration model to other models for
understanding the formation of Israel that
build on this archaeological evidence.
The second model is what
we call the revolt model.
The revolt model proposes that Israel
began really as a social revolution within
Canaan.
We do have a set of letters.
These are letters that date
from the 14th century BCE.
They were written by people in Canaan
to the Pharaoh in Egypt. Remember,
the Pharaohs still has control
over Canaan at this time.
And then these letters are lots of
complaints about groups that are causing
turmoil and upset in Canaan.
There challenging Egypt's rule and
these people are called [inaudible] or
[inaudible]. Um, they
weren't an ethnic group. Um,
so much as a marginal social
group of people in revolt,
if you will,
some have suggested that Israelites
escaping from Egypt may have joined with
these disaffected Canaanites in revolt
known as that be of these troublemakers,
um, to establish their own settlements
and to worship elaborator God. Yeah,
way rather than follow
the rule of Pharaoh.
A final model then is a
model of gradual emergence,
which simply holds that Israelites were
basically Canaanites who had developed a
separate identity and settled
increasingly in the central highlands.
They withdrew and settled in this area.
The theory doesn't try to explain
why they separated. We don't know.
Perhaps it was disaffection.
Perhaps they were pushed out by the
invading see peoples and maybe it was
something else.
But they withdrew for some reason.
And how and why they took up the worship
of Yahweh or the cult of Yahweh isn't
really clear,
but it seems to have been what marked
them as distinct from other Canaanites.
The [inaudible] may have been introduced
by people escaping slavery from Egypt.
Most scholars see the exodus story as
evidence for the presence of some escaped
slaves among this community. So the
important thing is that the Hebrews,
at this stage,
we're probably not a United people.
Various elements went into the final mix
that would emerge as the nation Israel
local Canaanites who for some reason
with drew and establish their own
settlements with a continuous
material culture and established, um,
agricultural lifestyle.
You have them,
you have escaping slaves from Egypt and
remember we do have some evidence of
destruction from outside,
so there could also have been some
foreigners coming in and destroying and
settling.
It even seems that some local foreigners
were admitted to the community.
We read of Midianites who
covenant into the community.
We read if Ken EITs who Covenant Covenant
into the community and archaeological
archeology supports this picture of
merging of people's, a picture of,
of the merging of peoples rather than
conquest or even large scale immigration
because the new settlements in this
period show such continuity with the past,
with the past,
not a complete break.
I'm not the initiation of
something radically new. And again,
some of the elements within this group
may have brought with them the story of a
miraculous escape from Egypt.
They may have understood this to be the
work of the halfway a god known probably
from southern regions and so the mixed
group that would join together to become
Israel accepted.
Yeah,
way though perhaps not exclusively and
adopted the national story of the exodus
as its own.
At some point the Hebrew tribes themselves
were likely still in the process of
formation,
but the tribal structure of Israelite
Society that would develop would be
strengthened by the natural division
of the land into these separate
geographical areas that only reinforced,
um,
the tribal tribalization of,
of society.
And these local tribes probably
did assimilate elements
of the local population.
We've really seen already,
um,
the ethnic mix of various elements
reflected in religious imagery and
institutions. We've seen that, yeah,
way is represented in terms
reminiscent of the tent dweller,
l the god of the semi nomadic tent dwell
in Hebrews and their patriarchs and
certainly it god of
the Canaanite Pantheon.
We've seen that Yahweh way
is also represented in terms
reminiscent of bowel of
the Canaanite Pantheon, the god of the
settled Canaanite population. In fact,
in the book of judges,
you will read of a temple to Israel's God,
the God of the Covenant. And
that temple is um, called, uh,
the temple to the god of
the covenant or bow buried.
The word Burrito means covenant.
It's referred to as bow breed.
It's referred to as El
Burrito or bile l breed.
And this is in reference to Yap way.
These terms are all used to describe
the God of the Covenant, so in short,
we really may hypothesize
a union of cultural,
religious and ethnic elements,
local Canaanite agriculturalists,
semi nomadic Hebrews,
perhaps of the exodus escaped slaves,
perhaps happy rule up here through a
disaffected or a group that's in revolt.
All of these would come together to
produce what would be a new political and
religious reality called Israel.
If so,
why does the book of Joshua
provides such a different account?
One of outside conquest by means of a
war led by the hosts of the Lord because
in this account,
military skill is much less important
than ritual preparation and purity, right?
The Israelites marched around Jericho
for six days with seven priests carrying
seven horns and the Ark of the covenant
and then with a blast and a shout,
the walls tumble.
The conquest is represented as
a miraculous victory by God.
That's emphasized in Joshua
24 12 it wasn't. It was God,
not the sword or the bow
that drove out the enemy.
And why the claim of the utter destruction
of the Canaanites when points to
close Canaanite origins, this
practice, which I mentioned before,
it was known as hair ram or the
ban is not unique to Israel.
I know some of you have
studied it in sections.
You looked at the inscription of King
Mesha can measure of Moab and there's a
very, a important famous inscription from
the Ninth Century BCE written by King
measure of Moab. MARV is to the south
east. No, so I'm bad with directions.
South West. Yeah, that's east.
Yeah. So kind of to the east,
southeast of the Dead Sea.
Um,
so king may show of my lab and
in the inscription he writes,
he boasts and the God emotion said to me,
go take Nivo from Israel.
So I went by night and fought against
it from the break of dawn until noon,
taking it in slaying all 7,000 men,
boys,
women and girls and maid servants for I
had devoted them to destruction for the
god, Ash, dark emotion referring to him.
It's likely that such claims
are hyperbolic in Moab and uh,
it's likely they were
hyperbolic in Israel,
but that doesn't lessen the shock value
for a modern reader even though war and
our time is no less
savage and no less brutal.
But the important question here is why a
biblical writer or editor would want to
insist that the Canaanites were
to be completely destroyed.
I think assertions of national identity
and independence are often predicated on
differentiation from others.
If the Israelites were in fact,
basically Canaanites who had withdrawn
from the larger collective who insisted
on the overlord ship of Galloway and
Canaanites who did not join them in this,
where a special threat
to the new, yeah, wisdom,
this same dynamic of intense sibling
rivalry appears again in the first few
centuries of the common era when some
Jews separated from others and in
differentiating themselves and creating
their own identity as Christians felt it
necessary to engage in devastating leave
at [inaudible] and violent rhetoric
against their fellow Jews. The
interesting thing, however,
is that we mustn't ignore another voice
that's in the biblical text and it's a
voice that adds a level of
complexity to this picture.
Because alongside the idealized portrayal
of the Israelite conquest in the first
half of the book of Joshua alongside
the call for the destruction of all
Canaanites, we find interesting
tales of alliances and um,
incorporation of various Canaanite groups.
Indeed who is one of the battles,
uh, one of the heroines of the battle
of Jericho, if not a Canaanite woman,
a prostitute,
no less named Rahab.
She declares her faith in the hallway
and she delivers the city into Joshua's
hands.
The biblical writers soft fit to preserve
and include this account of a heroic
Canaanite prostitute,
another Canaanite group. Uh,
the give me nights trick the Israelites
and to making a covenant with them and
it's a covenant the Israelites.
Then I feel bound to observe.
Michael Coogan has described
such stories as ecological tales.
They are attempts to explain the fact
that there are lots of Canaanite groups
included in Israel and we
need to understand and explain
that reality as much as
we are an ideological account in which
all Canaanites are obliterated are
destroyed.
At the very least these stories raise
questions about the biblical portrait or
portrayal of invasion and conquest and
at most they illustrate the biblical
writers taste for literary subversion.
Yet again,
something we'll see over and over the
imperative of preserving a distinct
identity.
It's based on giving up the worship of
other of other gods are older gods and
observing.
All that is written in the,
in the law of Moses is reiterated in
Joshua's farewell address in Joshua 23 and
in the Covenant Renewal Ceremony in 24
and the central idea is that there is one
proper response to God's mighty acts on
behalf of Israel and that is resolute
observance of the book of the Torah of
Moses without intermingling with the
peoples that remain.
So in Joshua 23 verses seven and eight,
do not under the names of
their gods or swear by them.
Do not serve them or bow down to them,
but hold fast to the Lord your God is you
have done this day and verses 11 to 13
for your own sakes.
Therefore,
be most mindful to love the Lord your
God for you should you turn away and
attach yourself to the
remnant of these nations,
to those that are left among
you and intermarry with them.
You joining them and they join in.
You know for certain that the Lord your
God will not continue to drive these
nations out before you. They shall
become a snare and a trap for you,
a scorge to your sides and thorns in
your eyes until you perish from this good
land that the Lord your God has given you.
In 24 the Israelites are assembled at
check them to renew the covenant and
Joshua be counts God's mighty deeds on
behalf of Israel and exhorts them to
choose whom they will serve. Yeah.
Highway. Who's done all of this for them,
so undeservedly or the gods of those
whose lands they are settling in and the
people are warned of God's jealousy.
He demands exclusive loyalty.
He will not tolerate any deviation
in service of alien gods.
The ban on intermarriage
here is quite specific.
It's directed against Canaanites only,
not all non Israelites
for very specific reason.
Religious purity marriage with Canaanites.
The people closest to you specifically
will lead to the worship of the of that
spouses,
God and Israel is to show
undivided loyalty to God or
God will take the gift of
the land from her as
he did the Canaanites.
One last remark for you to think about,
consider the position of the
Israelites in the sixth century.
The time of the final editing
of the Deuteronomistic history.
The Israelites are sitting
in exile in Babylon.
They're trying to make sense of the
tragedy that has befallen them the loss of
their land.
Consider how a text like Joshua 23 in
Joshua 24 would go a long way towards
explaining their fate
while retaining faith.
In way we're going to be turned to this
when we reached the conclusion of the
digital animistic history in second kings.